the Imperial Valley in Southern
California is one of the major
Battlegrounds in the war over Colorado
River water Farmers there use about a
quarter of that precious resource in his
series looking into whether California
is a water hog using way more than its
fair share a news now investigator Kyle
Payne headed south to find out Kyle
joins us here live in studio Kyle Brian
we got an education down in the Imperial
Valley that area has the most senior
water rights along all 1450 miles of the
Colorado River and they're not planning
on loosening the grip on those rights
anytime soon
okay which one
it's a lot of the river the law of the
river according to this Farmer in the
Imperial Valley the law of the river
says the farmers come first like it or
not it's hurtful to hear that what we're
doing is a waste of water and we're the
problem the problem is far older than
this fourth generation farmer Andrew
lime Gruber we've had this issue for
longer than I've been alive who seems
like part gatekeeper if you look at our
priority system it was based on first in
line first in use and part politician
you know you made the comment that I
sound like a politician well it's
because I've had to as Farmers we have
to wear many hats I have to to tell my
story because there's no one else to
tell it so he tells it like it is I hate
where the conversation is Led he's done
many interviews like this one where he's
portrayed as someone of a bad guy he
says no one ever mentions the good stuff
like how Imperial Valley Farmers have in
the last 20 years spent some half a
billion dollars on conversion systems
and saved a total of just under a
million acre feet of water per year
roughly enough water to service two and
a half million homes we have drip
systems sprinkler systems tail water
recovery systems he says Farmers there
have changed the orientation of the
fields to conserve water and then
they've lined dirt ditches with cement
and created reservoirs to catch water
that would otherwise be lost could you
be conserving more
well yeah that's uh that's the question
of the day is can we be conserving more
Robert shutler works for the Imperial
Irrigation District one of his jobs is
to write the mission statement and
vision for the district it's important
for us to protect the river and to
defend the farmers you're continuing to
use all the water we're yeah uh well and
we had that right that right even
extends to the massive overwhelming
amount of water these farmers use to
produce Alfalfa that leafy crop that
feeds the cows and feeds you and me and
a lot of the areas that farm along the
Colorado River Feed The Nation but at
what cause it makes them big money and
uses a ton of water in comparison an
eight-minute shower uses 20 gallons of
water while one bale of alfalfa drinks
up 650 gallons but the farmers say they
use all this water because the public
demands it the real question is is
growing the food supply for the nation a
beneficial use of water beneficial use
the long-standing basic principle
defining California water rights which
limits water use to what's quote
reasonably required and prohibits waste
that there's a new definition of what
Kent constitutes a beneficial use of
water bill hazenkamp manages the
Colorado River resources for Southern
California's Metropolitan water district
unfettered growing of Alfalfa in the
desert might not be a beneficial use
it's not a beneficial use for me to
plant thousands of Acres of quinoa if
there's not a market for it and even in
the face of the river drying up and the
highest temps and worst drought in
centuries the farmers aren't budging
particularly because if they can't Farm
their livelihood will go down the drain
why would we solve a Water Crisis and
then create a food crisis some farming
areas are dealing with the crisis in a
different way they're taking the
government up on its offer to let
fertile Fields go unplanted in exchange
for what amounts to hundreds of millions
of dollars it's a big thing here in
Blythe California about 200 miles south
of Las Vegas you can see it's dusty and
dry here and economies in some areas
that take the money also take a big hit
and that has everyone caught up in this
war on water saying the f word for us
that's the f word in the valley
following following is when Farmland is
allowed to lie idle during the growing
season the land basically stays bone dry
because there's no reason to water it
thus preserving some of the Colorado
River Supply but the choice to fallow is
just that a choice when it comes to
Colorado River water the farmer's cup
runneth over without the change in
legislation change in law we have to
work with them to incentivize them to
reduce
so for now until California and the
other six states that rely on Colorado
River water come to an agreement the
water in the desert will flood the
fields and to the Chagrin of most
southern Nevada the Alfalfa will
flourish and continue to fatten up the
food supply Nevada has been one of the
most vocal places against the growing of
Alfalfa and farming in the desert in
general but I guarantee you if you go to
the Rio buffet right now and you look at
their salad bar that produce is grown
right here so it's a little hypocritical
for them to call for the ending of
farming in the desert and then to
benefit off of the bounty it produces
Southern nevadans are hypocrites
I must say he was a very good sport and
was up for the debate and I thought you
our viewers would appreciate his Candor
tomorrow at 6 and 11 we dive in and look
at the amount of water Southern
California recycles and reuses and how
and whether they're doing all they can
and should be doing